oh crap Hellboy first trailer is finally
hit and I've been waiting to get my
first real good look at this thing
because it's coming out in April which
is coming up kinda quick ish and while I
have made a video saying that I like
that the trailer cycle has shortened and
you know we're not seeing year-out
trailers for nearly as much stuff as we
used to and it's now usually on a six
month this is about four months so this
feels like it's cutting it a little
close which on some levels kind of
inherently makes me nervous when a
studio seems to be delaying marketing a
product but anyway let's talk about this
now first of all background I have read
some of the the Hellboy comics I have
actually a fair number of the trades
from the original you know early Mineola
run as well as some of the BPRD stuff
it's good I like it a lot I like the
movies pretty well I like the second
guillermo del toro directing movie
significantly better than the first but
i do still like the first mostly
aesthetically I also like the Hellboy
animated films that were done as well so
I I'd like I like Hellboy pretty well
overall so getting into this there's
something there are a few things about
it that aren't quite clicking into place
it feels it feels disjointed it has the
rhythm of a TV spot which kind of is
off-putting for me when it's the first
trailer normally I'd expect something a
little bit with a little bit more of a
through-line now I don't expect a lot of
plot from a very first trailer and we
don't really get any here and I'm fine
with that but I usually expect something
you know with a little more of a clear
central focus and I didn't feel that
here now that's not necessarily
indicative of anything wrong with the
film it's just a problem with the
trailer so focusing in on things that
might be more indicative of the film
itself well actually before I even do
this I it's been a while since I've
talked about this the whole idea of
rebooting Hellboy I'm actually
completely okay with because as much as
I had liked the previous films
especially the second one they were very
much Guillermo del Toro's babies you
basically could have called it EML del
Toro's Hellboy and his aesthetic and his
way of doing things so informed of those
films that if you were to make an
adaptation that stuck much closer to the
source material you would get a
significantly different feeling film
I feel like this does this and like you
can take you like take Hellboy himself
for example now i'm stiii haven't fully
gotten used to this look yet especially
in motion I probably will you know I
it's hard for me to get over the the
look that the Ron Perlman and the makeup
he had I gave the whole thing but what
is different about this is that it's a
little rougher it's a little uglier
because that's kind of the thing about
Guillermo del Toro's movies he does
grotesque but he does it in a way that
is strangely beautiful this is more
going for grotesque that is legitimately
grotesque
and I think that's a decent way to
distinguish it and the overall vibe of
the things that are in the trailer side
from Hellboy himself seem to be more
informed by that sort of sensibility
that sort of ruffle or around the edges
you know just gritty feel to things
which you know his look has that in and
of itself so all that's pretty
consistent that's nice it's very clear
on that they are going with the comic
book thing of you know the world already
knows who he is he's famous as a
paranormal investigator and they seem to
be going that which is good because one
of the few really notable bad ideas that
Gamal dealt or introduced to to Hellboy
was the idea that the public didn't know
who he was and was like an urban myth
which thankfully he ditched for that
second movie but I need to stop
referencing
because this has nothing to do with
those but in any case it is sort of nice
that it didn't fall into that trap
because that was one of the few missteps
with that we do hear of it for me and me
McShane who I shouldn't double-check
this is he playing professor broom I
guess he is he seems to be heading the
BPRD a in any case I'm a hoping that
there'll be some you know proper
emphasis which is one of the things that
I always liked about help boys but
especially with his gun he's really
really big gun is that part of the
reason it's so big is cuz he's not a
very good shot so he needs something
that's you know gonna have a real a
fairly sizable blast radius I'm kind of
hoping they give us a little bit of that
he seems seems a bit on the on the
grouchy side which can work I hope they
don't overplay it because I feel like
you I feel like in some ways Hellboy
should evoke a little bit of the thing
from the Fantastic Four you know he's a
monster but there are things that give
him that bring him joy and he and he
likes a good time so I hope we don't
lose sight of that with this we got a
glimpse of Mila Jovovich I did not
realize was in this movie I'm guessing
as the villain it looks like we are
gonna be doing you know whatever this
thing's version of oh we want him to
fulfill his destiny as the bringer of
the apocalypse kind of thing which it
has always been a recurring thing across
the comic books and came up in the
previous movies as well which in a way
kind of makes me go do we have to do
that because like it has been brought up
repeatedly in the other versions I mean
that said that's that's a largely
speculation on my part the story may not
actually focus on that but that again
that's just going off what I see and
what I have to go off of and that's what
I where I end up landing and that's what
I end up thinking as far as anything
else I do like the moment with the woman
behind the counter asking for IDs like
are you serious
of course later we get a really quick
shot of that same woman blasting with a
shotgun and I always like older women
who can kick butt so that I
that kind of made me smile I dug that um
other than that it's just kind of left
me going I feel like you need a second
trailer I feel like I need one that
feels more focused and it gives me more
of a story tone and vibe to the thing
cuz right now I feel like all I've
gotten sold on is the aesthetic
differences between this and gambol del
Toro's and I'm down for that but I'd
kind of like a little bit more to sort
of sink my teeth into I mean I'll
probably see the movie regardless but
just in terms of what I would like to
see from future marketing material but
overall it's pretty good I do that I did
the thing that I usually do which is to
zero in on the stuff that might be
indicating something wrong or the stuff
that could go wrong again I can't stop
my brain from doing that and I'm sorry I
don't need to put a damper on anybody's
fun but David Harbour looks like he is
enjoying the part which is that's a big
help so yeah I guess I'll wrap it up
there this might be a shorter video on
the shorter side for me
so Hellboy trailer have you seen it what
did you think about it whatever your
thoughts are drop something down in the
comments let's talk about a whole bunch
of stuff you can do because there's
buttons and links and a p.o box and link
to patreon a whole bunch of other stuff
check them all out down in the
description if you don't want to yeah
that's ok because at the end of the day
you're the council I just run the
meetings and until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]